there is a one wheel and I love it to
death except tires flat again what if
only you had two wheels I don't actually
have any holes in this tire the problem
is that I've put 2,300 miles on this
tire and it's worn them down so much
that you can see all the the threading
inside of the tire and air is literally
seeping through this is the point when
you're supposed to replace the tire
months beforehand you're never supposed
to let tires get this bad and I let this
tire get that bad 2,300 miles how many
kilometers re thousands 700 kilometers
think I might have the record for the
most miles on any given tire of a one
wheel that's probably not true but I'm
gonna say it's true someone challenged
that and I can't even go more than a day
without having to pump it up
speaking of which lately like in the
last week it's gotten even worse see
online that people have done this mod
they literally replace the tire with a
treaded tire so that it can go off the
road and I was like man that's a really
cool idea I need a new tire I heard of
this online it's from a company called
Hoosier this is literally the exact same
tire that's on a one wheel except it has
treads this tire here it never had
treads like this this is my pride and
joy my favorite thing so I'm a little
nervous taking this to the tire shop
because they're gonna rip it apart and
I'm afraid that they might break it
erupt flea
in a way makes YouTube red for
sponsoring this video because the
biggest project we have ever done
it's just dropped lifeline is out you
can watch the first episode on corridor
digital right now for free so go check
it out it's the first sci-fi narrative
series on YouTube
link in the description maybe there's a
card in the corner or keep watching now
whatever but go watch lifeline at some
point here is the largest undertaking
ever done why are you even willing the
camp aren't you go watching this don't
[Music]
know yeah I want to get in the knife
sharpening no joke Jake it seems like
you you probably know a little bit about
knife sharpening whenever he's locked in
those Sennheiser Sam got me this sword
is very very nice birthday present it's
funny because we were constantly doing
these like fruit slicing videos or
things like that you know a katana is a
great thing to have in a youtube studio
because it's sweet all the katanas in
the studio are all like fake katanas
they're all just these dull decorational
ones that you'd get but this one isn't
and I thought those pretty cool figured
you know it's a good birthday present
for Nico I should probably write I don't
know I mean well if this is the reason
you're watching this right now is
because I noticed there's like an actual
like legit sword just sitting on Nico's
desk collecting dust and figured I
should bring it up I don't know it's
trying to do that subtle thing you know
the subtle like do some with that
instead of just let that gather dust you
know because it's really serious
heartfelt gift you know yeah put a lot
of work in that a lot of no I did mostly
to cliques that being said there's a lot
of thought I think there's some truth to
what you're saying Sam I think I should
hang out right above your desk oh you're
gonna really you're gonna literally just
hang it above your desk I'll take I'll
take that this is a real sword so you
want it out of harm's way like you just
like I guess nails
[Music]
totally doesn't feel like it's done me I
swear that this worked if you if you
have a katana you want it within arm's
reach eventually they can then just
break in or you know you have to chop
some stuff open sword if someone bumps
if someone's like even bumps the wall
that thing is gonna go flying off that
thing is like still pretty that is legit
shark nothing is just like gonna fly off
and impale you guys are just jealous how
cool this looks but you don't have nails
like level should maybe rethink this set
up that's kind of sketchy so fortunately
I have a lot of one mole friends and one
guy said he tried five different places
before he found the right tire place
that could do this sort of installation
so I'm gonna call them up and set up an
appointment
ron's tires and wheel could I set up an
appointment it's a little electric
skateboard that has a single wheel in
the center of it
another question is that okay if we
bring cameras to record it so I was
heading home to the train station last
night and my tire officially died that's
how close I cut it so if this doesn't
work then I don't have a one wheel for I
don't know how long's are in the office
of the wrongs tire and wheel place on
linker shim so the motor is actually in
the wheel yes the motor is right here
yeah I can see the connection there yeah
totally all right well you gonna come
back in a few unfortunately the guy who
knows how to change this tire is not
currently here right now
in order to replace the tire we have to
remove the entire motor from the device
I wish I'd have done this at home before
we came out here today so right now I'm
taking off the electronic plug cover as
you'll see right now oh there we go okay
[Music]
I'm glad they have tools here this is
great hey whoa
that feels weird man whoa all right so
I've been cooking up something pretty
cool in that printer because after the
success of my little anamorphic bokeh
mods I decided hey let's do a corridor
digital mod for the salmon eco lenses
anti-bully wait is this really hey yo
Nico that's or do what I've come to
never thought that I was gonna die
I think I can eat sandwiches anymore and
if I died from eating a sandwich
I just rather that close the casket and
say it was something else has much more
horrible
[Applause]
the coolest part of having my life saved
the sunglasses that lifeline angel was
wearing and those are sweet I'll wear
these forever
you got this data come on come on come
on
[Music]
the truth
whoa the wheel is more rounded the
regular one wheel tyre is fairly flat
this is very round so it's not as stable
but it should be like really tight turns
you lose your print done yet I'm taking
it out right now man that's how I die
this there's no way there's no way I'm
going on like this freak 3d printer
accident please alright so I couldn't
just you know leave this video off
without reviewing the new tire at all
Here I am at brand Park in Glendale and
what it allows me to do is go up the
fire roads that access the top of the
mountain here I'm gonna go all the way
to the top all the way to the very top
and hopefully get up there before sunset
I'm hoping to achieve today is to
basically just get a better feeling for
how this tire works so far I'm really
really liking it but let's see how it
handles the trails it's got a long ways
to go this just the beginning of the
trail one of my favorite things to do is
ride up this mountain the city is so
full of hustle and work it can be
stressful overwhelming I like to come
out here to get away from it trail here
goes all the way
the very top it's about three or four
miles long but about 2,000 feet in
elevation oh god I almost just ran over
a lizard probably could handle it if I
had a little bit more speed but I was
filming and got distracted walking is my
least favorite thing and I'm at 8%
battery this is a homemade battery that
I made out of a couple 6l lipo so I'm
gonna use this to go through solar
controller this acts as a go-between
between solar panels and battery pack or
another battery pack in a different
battery pack I'll sometimes pass bikers
as a struggling for breath eyes wide as
they witness me riding by without any
effort I like to console them with the
line I'm cheating which which usually
gets a laugh but as I pull ahead of them
I tend to wonder if that's even true and
just like that I'm charging the one
wheel on the side of the mountain I know
what you're thinking this battery it
kind of looks like a bomb it's not a
bomb I mean it could be what exactly am
i cheating the exercise all I want is to
escape and since I've started coming up
here and discovering just how easy it is
to break out of the grind
I've been happier right there is where
I'm trying to go but in order to get
there I have to go all the way up and
around and all the way to the top and
over and along so it's really peaceful
up here but it's also stupidly fun I've
been snowboarding for 15 years and it
never gets old there's there's like this
magic to maneuvering your body using
only your balance gliding wherever you
choose to riding that raw connection
between mind and mountain the ability to
have that same experience while going up
hill is incredibly liberating
[Music]
pretty sweet view of Downton on that is
another problem that I'm just now
finding is that rocks are kind of
getting stuck between the treads and
then getting stuck between the foot pads
and the tire itself not too big of an
issue so far I've made it all the way up
here
maybe here you go you ready look at that
sunset
it's hard not to feel like you're flying
when at the end of it all you're 2,000
feet up overlooking a city you so
casually escaped
just a sheer cliff right here no big
deal
just about two feet wide in a cliff
everyone else they're just simply
missing out that was cool I I do really
want to note that I have done this right
before on the old one wheel tire in fact
I've done it many many times but what
makes this new tire different on this
ride is that I felt way more secure
riding up this road because on some of
the steeper parts of the road on the
older tire it would slip out there would
be just not enough friction between the
tire and the ground and it would slide
out and you'd fall off look at this view
is this not a great view or what thanks
for watching guys this was a fun ride
and I'll see you in the next video maybe
we can do another adventure together
hopefully that was all in focus in
exposed well enough so the biggest
project we've ever worked on is finally
released
right now on the quarter channel it's
called lifeline if you haven't heard of
it and the first episode is free the
rest are on YouTube red big thanks to
YouTube bread for sponsoring this video
on the show it and it's gonna be it's
gonna be great you should watch it right
now
it's the biggest undertaking Sam and I
have ever done we shot for 40 days
straight 12-hour days eight half-hour
episodes on YouTube red and here's the
thing if you're gonna fan of things we
do in the office well this is what it's
for guys it's for projects like this
this is us trying to actually achieve
that dream if you want to see what it
looks like
head on over to corridor and check it
out there's also a three month free
trial of YouTube right going on right
now so if you were like sure you do
bread yet just hit that little free
trial button right now and you can check
out the whole show so there's basically
no reason not to watch it man that's
solid logic like why wouldn't you yeah
if you're like oh why are you releasing
on YouTube are you gonna release it's on
YouTube guess what it's about people who
time travel time travel they can travel
33 days into the future to save your
life if they think you're gonna die or
detect it you're gonna die now someone
might say that makes no sense why would
you time travel 33 days into the future
why not just like wait 33 days well
guess what it's a sci-fi show we've made
up all these reasons that make sense
and back up that concept and the premise
and the only way you're gonna figure out
what those are by watching the Diggity
dang show anyways so hopefully it's
still going on by the time this video
gets released